so you're you're mad about your co-star
paul riser he was just here what did he
say well he said that you and his wife
are pretty close so did y'all ever talk
about his issues because i'm sure there
are some he's a comedian um i think we
dealt with every issue either of us had
because after seven years and then we
did a reboot which you can watch right
now after this show you can watch it on
amazon yeah um you know it was eight
years of bringing your issues to the
table and turning them into episodes so
we know each other pretty well at this
point did you ever do that with your
issues because i feel like that's kind
of i do that with writing songs that's
why you should probably never date a
songwriter i was like hey that's rough
my daughter and i were listening to just
a vicious song by a brilliant songwriter
i thought boy do not piss off
a songwriter i'm gonna remember that i
know did you ever do that did you bring
your real life stuff to you yeah i mean
to matt about you we just
showed up and said this morning at
breakfast like you just had to keep
making episodes but i've written two
movies and and
they say is it autobiographical and
someone very smart said it is but i'm
every character
so i think that's kind of what it's like
when you're writing a movie yeah that
must take so much time
[Music]
you